hey youtube how the fudge you doing jake
here what's going on guys listen you
like that intro cole anyway we're doing
a replay review
for blood
he's like champ two
and he wants to be gc by the end of the
season so let's see what he's doing
wrong so like right here
great great stuff
i think you just you know
what what do i say here work on your
aerials because you you hit it away from
yourself so like you had all the control
everything you want this is ever this is
this is exactly what you want and you
just kind of lost it i don't know
practice your your off the wall stuff
because you even got the bump on the guy
yeah i mean that's just one mechanical
mistake
this is a decisional decision mistake
so like 53 boost though
i mean
i can see why you jumped i like this
rotation i like that you're picking up
pads
that's great man
but this ball is like way too high and
it's like right pretty much right above
you it's like you're going back you're
rotating tox goes for a ball decent 50.
he's on the wall it's just too risky
because it goes right past you like you
just didn't have enough boost to go for
the ball that's directly above you if
you had like some leeway
i think it's a good one to go for but
when a ball is right above you it takes
way more boost to get to the ball i
think this is this decision you don't
make there but you got
your boy back doing nothing
okay you got lucky bloggers you don't
commit to this you don't want to be your
teammate who's making a mistake here
yeah let's all let's all just jump into
the corner man
basically what you're doing you actually
got lucky you got bumped
so you could recover faster this is what
happens a lot in champ guys
is that
people make a mistake and then they
follow it up with another mistake which
is basically the same mistake you're
pretty much doing exactly what tox did
which is getting bald
and getting lucky that that didn't go
right in your in your net if you all
have been watching me for a long time
what did i not like about this
he gets the boost what does he do
why are you flipping dog now you're up
in a play that you can't even get to
he took both boots too i'm not super mad
about that
but these flips bro i'm telling you
oh
they just throw you out of position
because guess what i can tell right here
that you're not gonna get this ball
you're just not
now you're really not getting this ball
because you have to go through this in
this flip animation
that you're now in front of the play
with
and now it just goes over your head so
like it doesn't really matter i know
you're just pressuring
but
i hate it when people flip for no reason
bro
because if that guy is better he's gonna
shoot that on your net and you lose you
get scored on so that we've seen this
like three or four times from blood so
far
look at where tox is
i'll say tox is bad
dude his pressure does nothing he he
goes for the play he goes through the
ball and he misses
we're not even a minute into this game
and he's gone
pressured ball chasing and doesn't even
hit the ball you don't want to do the
same thing
which you've done three four times now
and you have also missed the ball so
let's look at talks here just just for
quick reference of what you should not
do
he's rotating on the wall with no boost
what does he do here chat
like why
stop flipping
you all flip way too much
this is so dumb
like he's shadowing fine and then he
flips
now it's a free goal for the other team
and he was ball side rotating
in twos i'm a little bit more lenient
about ball side because sometimes it's
inevitable but talks did not make that
easy at all blood you didn't make that
easy either because you're going for a
bunch of balls that you haven't even hit
there's another ball you haven't hit
so like i would say that's five or six
times in the first minute and 10 seconds
of this match
that you go for a ball
that you could hit and you miss
and it leads to pressure against your
team and
basically two goals now i don't know why
you're air rolling that's a good point
an rv
there's no point to an air roll here
just fly to the ball
that would have been a lot easier you
could be a little bit faster in the air
i think your movement around the field
so far is great
your rotation is actually really good
you're just kind of slow probably at
this point in the match you should be
thinking to yourself i don't trust talks
right guys has anyone else gotten that
vibe from talks this match where it's
like
i don't think
i should give any trust into this
person at all right
lud you're giving a lot of like this guy
is not hitting this to you
he barely he jumped on a ball that he
could hit off the bounce this ball is
gonna come at you if he does hit it at
like four miles an hour which is not
ideal for an outlet pass that you want
really bad
and he missed
so you get your ass back in the net i
like it good stuff
this is fine
it's not
i didn't think they would shoot it bro
all right chat what is wrong with ludd's
position in here
so you should be here
if you're here watch how easy this save
is
you jump a little bit and you hit that
just bad positioning you got to be i
would get your butt in on the line
or a little bit inside and all
defending gets so much easier bro like
holy [ __ ] i wanted to fall asleep for a
second you driving around here like
you can have a little sense of urgency
man
like
go you know what i'm saying like this
would be the time to flip
you know how i yell you about flipping
all the time this is a time where you
flip
and you grab pads
whereas you're like a turtle
oh
like a turtle
driving around
just you're just kind of slow at the
wrong times that was a good
little little challenge
god talks is bad i think a better play
here is just faking
don't even go for it fake it let them
carry it around the wall and then you
control it
but
you got lucky
that that guy doesn't know how to shoot
what
i'm not gonna look at it i don't know
why you just got a goal but great job
great shot dude
you should have got scored on and you
got a goal welcome to champ that's just
a mechanical error all right chet so you
know i think we found your problem blood
we've got the problem down
how many times have you done this in the
first half of the match
no you're not this isn't slow this is
you just don't go for it this guy's got
you beat by a mile i i know you can hit
this ball you could be a little bit
faster and you can block it right
i want to hear one person in chat give
me the reason that he doesn't aerial
this ball tox is in southeast asia
exactly philly
your last man
talks is out of position again
and you're going for a ball that you
don't need to go for
toxins and narnia
the other team sucks like that's the
only reason you didn't get scored on
they suck what's the percentage you get
this aerial
zero don't do that ever again i hate
that
wait for the next hit you drive to the
backboard you clear this out i'm not
going to ask you because we've already
gone through this you're way outside the
net where should you be you should be on
the goal line or slightly inside the net
i don't care where front back middle if
you're a little bit inside the net this
is much easier you're better than tox
but man
cox is
struggling this match you should have
got this ball though
i don't know what what is tox doing
god okay
i like it
solid
good pass
i don't know why you're passing the
talks though
we're passing again to talks
oh okay
this is why i hate champ like where was
that the entire game
[Music]
excuse me champ two by the way
man that's bad i want to see where tox
was this entire time okay he's getting
mid boost
you basically pass it to the other team
what happened here
[Music]
this is a big problem for you man you
are positioned outside the net in
defense
a lot i know this was an awkward play
but you need to get your butt in the net
at least on one of the sides
yeah you turn a little bit too fast you
did not have the best teammate that game
i will give i will put some you know
like that wasn't very good teamwork
you guys had one good passing play i
think but hey
there was a lot that you could have done
better that match your decision making
on your aerials is pretty bad like you
need to work on that absolutely like
you're you're just either too slow or
you go for a ball that you just don't
need to go for at all work on either
your speed on your aerials and your
decision making when it comes to them
your boost routing and rotation is
really good i liked it i didn't have any
problem with um
your rotations besides the uh defensive
rotation you're just outside of the net
tuck it in get on that line or a little
bit inside defense just gets easier when
you do that
that's like defensive
stuff number one get get on the line or
inside everything gets easier it wasn't
that bad of gameplay you guys almost
came back and while you didn't have the
best teammate teammate ever you didn't
make it easier for him and you made it
easier for the other team in a lot of
regards you got to look at where your
teammates at if they're out of position
you got to get in position you can't
just it'll lead to goals
if you don't so
hopefully that was helpful man